sine of angle a the capital letters are
for the angles over the side opposite so
you can think of these as a pair equals
the sine of angle B over its side
opposite these are a pair equals the
sine of angle C over its side opposite
so you only need to use two of these
three ratios to form a proportion so
I'll give you an example so let's take
for example this triangle here okay say
this angle is 60 degrees
say this side over here is 8 say this
angle here is a hundred degrees and say
we want to find the side that's across
from that angle we'll just call this
side X so what you want to think of when
you do the law of sines is you want to
think of the angle in the side opposite
are a pair so 60 and eight form a pair
100 and X form a pair so what we're
gonna do is we're going to make a
proportion using the law of sines the
sine of 60 over 8 equals the sine of 100
degrees over its side opposite X and
then what we're going to do is we're
going to cross multiply across the equal
sign and we get eight sine 60 sorry
eight sine 100 multiply on the diagonal
equals X sine 60 and then all we have to
do is divide by sine of 60 sine is 60
divided by sine 60 degrees these are
going to cancel and X is going to equal
that quantity right there so let's just
check real quick and see what that is on
the calculator so let's see my mode
let's see I am in degrees okay that's
good and let's see we've got eight sine
100 divided by sine 60
okay 9.1 approximately okay so that's
the law of sines now what comes up with
the law of sines that oftentimes
confuses students is what they call the
ambiguous case so we're going to talk
about the ambiguous case this is where
there can be two triangles there can be
one triangle there can even be no
triangle given the information that they
give you in the problem so let me see if
I can show you how that works and let's
take a look at that
okay so when you do the law of sines the
ambiguous case it occurs when you have
side-side-angle
and the reason I wrote it like that is
because this is going to be an acute
angle the side next to that acute angle
is going to be longer than the side
across from that acute angle so I'll
show you what I mean so say for example
this is 30 degrees and say this is 10
and say this side over here is 6 okay
what you want to do is you want to drop
an altitude like that so now what we
have is we have a right triangle right
here on the left and we're going to find
out what is that altitude so to do that
we're just going to use regular right
triangle trigonometry sine of 30 degrees
equals I'll call that H H over 10 so
sine of 30 equals opposite hypotenuse
what you can do is you can cross
multiply on the diagonal and you get H
equals 10 times the sine of 30 degrees
sine of 30 is 1/2 times 10 is 5 so this
height is 5 okay now here's where the
analysis comes in this side right here
we don't know anything about this angle
okay we don't know anything about this
angle this side here you could rotate
this side in such a way that it could
actually be like that so you could
rotate it so this triangle could even
could either be like this or you can
rotate it like that because we don't
know what this angle is it's not fixed
so what we end up here in this situation
where this side across from the acute
angle is in between the altitude and the
side adjacent that's when you get two
triangles okay now say for example this
side over here instead of being six it
was four
well if it was for it would only be like
this long right here and if you rotate
it so you think of this as a hinge if
you rotate it it's not going to be long
enough to reach this side so in that
case there would be no triangle possible
now if this was exactly five it would be
a right triangle if this side was
greater than ten again think of this as
a hinge it was greater than ten if we
swung this side over here it would be
too long it wouldn't intersect the side
it would actually go past this side
right here so in that case you're just
gonna have one triangle possible it'd
have to swing out like that so these are
the different cases with the law of
sines let's take a look at how to solve
this problem that has two triangles and
then we can look at some other examples
so the first thing you want to do is
let's label this triangle a B and C this
is going to be side a side C and a side
B across from each other so what we're
going to do here is we're going to do
the law of sines sine a 30 over 6 equals
sine of C over 10 sine of 30 over 6
equals
sign of go to this side here sign of see
over 10 so again if we crop if we
multiply both sides by 10 these tens are
gonna cancel okay and if we simplify the
son or calculator let's see what that
comes out to 10 times the sine of 30
divided by six point eight three so I'm
just going to round point eight three
equals the sine of C and then if you
take the sine inverse of both sides
that's how you solve for angle C so C is
the sine inverse of 0.8 three let's do
that sine inverse 0.8 three we get fifty
six point four degrees let's just call
it fifty six for this example keep it
simple now what I want you to realize is
when we took this side here and we swung
it like this this actually forms an
isosceles triangle so this is 6 this is
6 if this is 56 degrees which we just
solve for this here will also be 56
degrees and by doing 180 minus 56 we can
solve for this angle right here so what
we've got here is we've got this
triangle okay that's this one right here
and we have this is a possible triangle
right here so if this is 56 this would
be 180 minus 56 which is 124 so this is
going to be a hundred and twenty-four
this is 56 this is 30 and this is 30 and
what else do we know this is 6 this is
10 this is 6 this is 10 and so now what
you can do is you can add these two
angles together and subtract from 180 to
find this angle you can add these two
angles together subtract from 180 to
find this angle so let's do that that's
86
so this must be 94 this one here is 154
which means this must be 26 okay now
what you're gonna do is you're going to
solve for this missing side right here
by doing the law of sines again so sine
of 26 over the side opposite equals sine
of 30 over its side opposite same thing
here sine of 94 over its side opposite
equals sine of 30 over its side opposite
and that's how you're going to solve for
these two missing sides so in this case
you get two triangles and again that's
because this side was in between the
altitude and the side adjacent so
there's actually two possible triangles
so that's the law of sines the ambiguous
case and now what I want to do is just
talk a little bit about how to find the
area of a triangle if it's not a right
triangle if you don't have the altitude
and let's just take a look at that next
okay so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna find the area of a triangle so say
for example your triangle is like this
say this is 10 say this is 70° say this
is 15 okay you want to find the area of
the triangle now before we learn the
formula for the area of a triangle was
what 1/2 base times height the base is
the bottom the height is this right here
okay the altitude that's how tall the
triangle is well we don't have the
height so how we're going to be able to
solve for the height what we can do is
we can do sine of 70 equals H over 10 so
sine of 70 degrees equals H over 10 by
cross multiplying we get H equals 10
times sine of 70 so let's see what that
is 9 point 4 we're round and now we can
do one half the base 15 times the height
9 point 4 we have the area of the
triangle so let's just write that down
one half the base which is 15 times the
height which is nine point four but
where do we get to 9 point 4 from it was
10 times the sine of 70
so what I want to point out here is that
this is one way to find the area of the
triangle the other way to find the area
of the triangle is to use this formula
right here that I'm going to show you
next let's go over here to this side so
say you know this angle I'm just going
to write a for angle a and you know this
side let's say that we'll call this side
one and this side two if you want to
find the area of this triangle all you
have to do is do 1/2 times side 1 times
side 2 times the sign of the included
angle included means in between those
two sides so sine of angle a okay right
here and that's it that's the area of
the triangle so it's very easy so if you
have side angle side the angles in
between two sides all you have to do is
do one half the two sides multiplied
together times the sine of the included
angle and you got it so a quick example
would be like this
say this is 30 degrees I like 30 because
30 is easy to find the sign of and then
you've got 8 and let's say this is 10 so
very simply it's going to be 1/2 8 times
10 times the sine of 30 degrees so if
you multiply all those together you get
1/2 times 8 times 10 is 40 times the
sine of 30 sine of 30 is 1/2 so that's
going to be 20 units squared ok so law
of sines ambiguous case and how to find
the area of a triangle when you don't
have the altitude you can use this
formula one half side one times side two
times the sine of the included angle
alright check out some of my other
videos if you have other things that you
want to learn about math wise feel free
to review this video if you want to pick
up some additional pointers just go
through it a second time and keep on
studying